Hello guys, welcome to our vlog and well
this is an AI vlog created by Zapiwala
using Google way 3. Guys, welcome again.
We are going to our honeymoon in
Bangkok. Stay tuned to Zapiwala to
learn.
Thank you Zapiwala for sponsoring this
amazing honeymoon trip. If you want to
learn how this video has been generated
then stay tuned. Namaste. First night
out in Bangkok and we're hunting street
food with Zapiwala and Google Veo 3.
Yeah,
all these stunning videos you're seeing
have been generated using Google V3. And
let me tell you, V3 is hands down the
most powerful AI video generator
available right now. If you've been
dreaming of creating cinematic,
hyperrealistic AI videos, then mastering
prompt writing for V3 is absolutely
essential. In this tutorial, I'm going
to reveal seven powerful tips to help
you craft the perfect prompt for Google
V3. But that's not all. Somewhere in
this video, I'll also share with you a
magical prompt template. Yes, the exact
one I used to generate these
breathtaking visuals. So, if you're
serious about leveling up your AI video
game, stay with me till the very end
because you won't want to miss a single
insight. Before we jump in, do me a
small favor. Smash that like button and
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already. I'm putting my heart into these
videos and your support really helps me
grow this small but passionate creator
community. All right, no more waiting.
Let's dive right
in. If you want to create cinematic
videos using Google V3, then the first
prompt tip you need to follow is start
strong with the cinematic hook. This
means the very first sentence of your
prompt sets the entire tone, camera
setup, and visual style. If you skip
this, VO might generate a flat, generic
looking clip. Think of it like directing
your first shot. You're choosing the
emotion, composition, and lighting right
from the start. Now, if your prompt is
vague or weak, you simply won't get that
polished cinematic result. Let's take a
look at an example of a bad prompt. You
might be wondering, why exactly is this
a bad prompt? Well, there are a few key
reasons. First, there's no clear mood or
visual style. Words like peaceful are
too generic. They don't guide Vio on how
the scene should actually feel. Second,
there's no mention of camera type or
movement. Third, there's no emotional
cue from the character. We don't know
what the girl is feeling or expressing.
And finally, there's no dialogue. The
character doesn't say anything. She's
just there, silent and passive. So,
taken together, this prompt ends up
feeling vague and flat. Before we move
ahead, let's actually create a video
using this prompt and see how it turns
out. To do this, go to Google Flow to
access Google V3. Now, if you don't yet
have access to V3, no worries. I've got
you covered. Check out the video where I
walk you through step by step how to get
access to Google V3 completely free for
the next 15 months. Once you're inside
Google Flow, click the settings icon
here. Select the number of output videos
per prompt. I'm choosing one just to
save some credits. Next, go to the video
model dropown and choose highest quality
VO3. Now, paste in your prompt and hit
the send button. Within just a few
seconds, your video will be ready. And
bingo, here it is. Let's take a
[Music]
look. Okay, so it's not a bad video, but
clearly it's missing that cinematic
spark, and that's because the prompt
itself wasn't strong enough. Now, you're
probably wondering, what does a good
prompt look like? Here it is. A
wide-angle golden hour shot captures a
young woman standing alone in a
sun-drenched wheat field. The lens
catches soft flares as she looks into
the sky and says clearly, "I think I'm
ready to start over." Why is this prompt
so much better? First, it opens with
cinematic language. Terms like wide
angle and golden hour instantly give VO
visual direction. Second, there's a
defined atmosphere. We can picture the
soft flares, the sundrenched field.
Third, there's emotion. The woman isn't
just standing there. She's looking up.
She's alone. And the lighting reflects
her state of mind. It tells a story
without overexplaining. And finally, we
have dialogue. I think I'm ready to
start over. That single sentence gives
emotional weight and clarity. It tells
us something important is changing for
her and that pulls the viewer in.
Together, all these details make the
scene feel cinematic, intentional, and
full of life. All right. Now, let's go
ahead and create a video using this good
prompt. Just enter the prompt into the
prompt box and hit send. Give it a few
seconds and here it is the final video.
Let's preview this one too.
[Music]
Now this feels cinematic. Notice the
warmth of the lighting, the composition
of the wide-angle lens, the emotional
expression on her face, and that
powerful line of dialogue. It's not just
pretty. It feels like a scene from a
film. That's the power of a well-crafted
prompt. Now, you must be wondering, how
can you write a strong prompt like that?
Well, don't worry. I've got you covered.
Here's a prompt template you can follow
to create cinematic hooks like this
every time. Just fill in the blanks with
your story idea, and you're on your way
to professional looking cinematic shots.
Now, let's move on to tip two.
Now that you've set a strong cinematic
hook, it's time to focus on the core
visuals. Telling VO exactly who is in
the shot, what they're doing, and where
they are. Think of this like a
storyboard panel. Your subject should be
the clear centerpiece of the scene.
Avoid vague verbs like doing something,
or looking. Now, let's look at this bad
prompt. A man is in a city. He's
walking. Again, why is this a bad
prompt? First, what does he look like?
We have no idea. Is he cleancut or
scruffy? Tall or short? Nervous or calm?
Without character description, Vio has
no visual direction. Second, what's the
city like? Is it modern, grimy,
historical, neon lit? City is far too
generic to paint a clear picture. Third,
what is he wearing? Clothing tells us
about personality, social status, or
even the mood of the scene. A man with
no outfit gives Vio no visual texture.
Fourth, is it day or night? This
matters. Lighting defines tone. Whether
it's bathed in harsh daylight or moody
shadows makes a big difference in the
final video. Fifth, the prompt misses
all visual cues. No steam, no signage,
no bystanders, no weather. The
environment is completely blank. And
finally, there's no dialogue. He doesn't
say anything. We don't hear his thoughts
or motivations. So overall, this prompt
fails to provide any defining detail.
It's like asking Vio to shoot a scene
with the lights off and no script. Now
let's create a video using this prompt.
To do this again, simply paste the
prompt into VO3 and hit the send button.
Wait for a few seconds and bingo, here
is our generated video. Let's preview
this. As expected, it's basic, vague,
and visually flat. There's nothing that
really draws you in. No atmosphere, no
personality, no story. And that's
exactly why we need clear, rich core
visuals in our prompt. Now, let's look
at a better version of this prompt. A
disheveled man in a wrinkled brown coat
walks briskly through a neon lit Tokyo
alley at night. Steam rises from the
grates. He pauses, looks at a flickering
sign, and says clearly, "I've been here
before, but something's different." Now,
why is this a strong prompt? First
character detail. We're not just told a
man. We're shown a disheveled man in a
wrinkled brown coat walking briskly that
gives us an instant mental image, a
sense of urgency, and even a hint of his
backstory just through appearance and
movement. Second, setting specificity.
This isn't just a city. It's a neon lit
Tokyo alley at night with steam rising
from the grates. Every detail adds
texture and atmosphere. We can see it,
feel it, even hear it. Third, emotion
through environment. The flickering
neon, the night setting, the brisk walk,
it all builds tension and mystery. You
can tell something's off. The mood isn't
just told, it's felt through the
visuals. And finally, the character
speaks. That single line of dialogue,
I've been here before, but something's
different. Adds narrative weight.
Together, these elements transform the
scene from generic to cinematic. Now,
let's see how this looks as a video.
Just enter the prompt into VO, hit send,
and give it a few seconds. And here it
is. Let's preview it.
I've been here before, but something's
different.
Now that looks and feels like a real
movie scene, rich in detail, emotion,
and story. And that's the magic of
strong core visuals. And here's a prompt
template you can use to guide your
scene. Just fill in the blanks, and
you've got a solid, storyrich prompt
ready to go. And with that, let's move
on to tip three.
All right. So far, you've hooked the
viewer with a cinematic opening and
built a strong visual core by defining
who, what, and where. Now, it's time for
the next tip that transforms your video
from a shot into a world. Tip three,
atmosphere and sensory details, the
immersive layer. This is where your
prompt stops being just visual and
becomes emotional. Atmosphere turns a
technical scene into something that
feels alive. It's about light, sound,
color, texture, the tiny details that
give the moment depth, mood, and
realism. These aren't just extras.
They're emotional triggers. Let's look
at a bad example. It's kind of dark.
There's a tree. It's windy. Now, what's
wrong with that? Well, it's vague and
generic. Kind of dark doesn't tell Vio
how to light the scene. There's no
texture, no mood, no sensory detail.
Windy is just a word. We don't hear it,
feel it, or see it. And again, no
dialogue, no story. Let's test this one
out. Paste it into VO3. Hit send. Wait a
moment. And here's the result. Let's
preview
it. Yeah, it works technically, but it's
lifeless. Now, here's a strong example
of the same scene, but layered with
atmosphere. Pale moonlight filters
through twisted trees, casting long
shadows on the mossy ground. A low fog
drifts between roots as leaves rustle
softly. A girl stands barefoot, holding
a lantern, and says clearly, "The forest
remembers everything, even the lies."
Let's break down why this will work so
well. Light and shadow, pale moonlight,
long shadows. Now Vio knows how to light
the scene. Texture and sound, mossy
ground, fog, rustling leaves. We can
feel the environment. mood. The scene is
eerie, mysterious, almost haunting just
from the atmosphere. And finally,
dialogue. The forest remembers
everything, even the lies. That line
gives the scene emotion, mystery, and
narrative weight. Let's plug that prompt
into V3. Hit send. Wait a few seconds,
and boom. Here's our video. Let's
preview it.
The forest remembers everything, even
the lies. Now, that feels immersive.
You're not just watching it, you're
inside it. So, how do you write prompts
that create that kind of sensory depth?
Don't worry, I've created a simple
template you can use. Just fill in the
blanks with your scene idea, and you'll
instantly bring your world to life with
mood, texture, and emotion. Now, let's
move into tip
four. Tip four, motion choreography and
camera movement. Now that your scene has
texture and atmosphere, it's time to
bring in motion and not just from your
subject, but from the camera itself.
This is what separates a static shot
from one that feels like real cinema.
You see, VO3 isn't just a texttovideo
tool. It understands how to simulate
real camera work if you guide it
properly. You need to tell it what the
subject is doing and what the camera is
doing in response. Think like a director
of photography. Are we tracking behind
the character? Is it a handheld shot? A
slow pushin? Is the camera still or
chaotic? Let's look at a bad prompt
first. The man runs and the camera shows
it. Why doesn't this work? We don't know
how he runs. Is it a sprint, a stumble,
or a casual jog? The camera direction is
unclear. Shows it doesn't tell VO
anything. Is it handheld or smooth?
What's the emotion here? We don't feel
anything. And once again, no dialogue.
Now, let's plug that into V3. Hit send.
Wait a few seconds and yep, here is the
video. Let's preview
it. The result is about what we
expected, flat and forgettable. Now,
here's how we fix it. Let's rewrite the
scene with proper subject motion and
camera choreography. A handheld camera
tracks a panicked man sprinting down a
dim hospital corridor. Fluorescent
lights flicker overhead. He skids to a
stop at a closed door and shouts, "Is
anyone in there? Please answer me." Now
that feels cinematic. Why? Clear subject
motion. He's sprinting. He skids.
There's urgency. Defined camera work.
Handheld camera tracks. Vio knows how to
move the shot. Environment and mood. The
flickering lights and corridor add
tension. And finally, dialogue. His line
pulls us into the moment emotionally.
Let's test this prompt inside V3. Paste
it in. Hit send and boom. Preview this
generated video. Is anyone in
there? Please answer me. Now that feels
like a movie scene. There's motion,
chaos, emotion. It's alive. So, how do
you write this kind of prompt? Here's a
template you can steal. It's time to
move to tip five.
We've built your scene with strong
visuals, motion, and atmosphere. Now,
it's time to think like a
cinematographer. Composition guides the
viewer's eye. Tip five, compositional
language. Frame with intention. Even AI
understands concepts like the rule of
thirds, depth, focus, symmetry, and
negative space. Your prompt needs to
explain how to frame the shot, not just
what is in it. Here's a bad example. The
man is in the middle, and some trees are
behind him. Why doesn't this work? No
clear framing or focus. The subject just
exists in the scene. We don't know the
relationship between the man and his
environment. Background is generic and
lacks detail. There's no visual depth or
layered interest. And again, no dialogue
to ground us emotionally. Now, paste
that prompt into VO3. Hit send. Wait a
few seconds. And here's the generated
video. Let's preview
it. As expected, it looks flat and
uninteresting. The shot doesn't guide
your eye anywhere and the scene feels
uninspired. Now, let's see a stronger
example. Framed in the lower third, a
man kneels beside a campfire as flames
dance in the blurred foreground. Behind
him, snow-covered trees fade into
darkness. He looks at the flames and
says calmly, "I never thought I'd make
it this far. Why is this prompt strong?"
The subject is intentionally placed in
the lower third, giving the shot dynamic
balance. Foreground flames are blurred,
creating depth and drawing focus to the
man, while background details like the
snow-covered trees fading into darkness
add atmosphere and mood. The composition
supports a calm, reflective tone. The
dialogue adds emotional weight and story
context. Now, let's test that in V3.
Paste this improved prompt into V3. Hit
send. Wait a moment. And boom. Here's
the video. Let's preview it.
I never thought I'd make it this far.
Notice how the composition pulls you in.
The blurred flames add depth. The man's
placement offc center creates interest.
And the fading trees add atmosphere. The
dialogue gives it emotional weight.
Here's a simple template you can use to
frame your shots like a pro. With this
compositional language, your videos
won't just show, they'll draw the viewer
in exactly where you want. Ready for tip
six? Let's keep rolling.
By now, you've mastered visuals, motion,
atmosphere, and framing. But there's one
thing that can still break your prompt,
and that's vagueness. Your words are the
camera, and every single one has to earn
its place. When you write for VO, don't
think like a novelist. Tip six,
conciseness and precision. Every word
counts. Be visually specific. Don't
write like pros. Avoid generic or
emotional terms unless you show how they
manifest visually. Eliminate filler like
maybe, kind of, or somehow. Let's look
at a weak example. A nicel looking
place, maybe a house. It feels
mysterious. Here's why this fails. Nice
means nothing. It could be a cabin, a
castle, or a kitchen. Maybe weakens the
image. You're not sure, so why should VO
be? Feels mysterious is an emotion, but
we don't see what creates that feeling.
And once again, no dialogue to ground
the scene. Let's test this in V3. Paste
the prompt. Hit send. Wait a few
seconds. And here's the generated video.
Let's preview
it. As expected, generic, forgettable,
and empty. Now, let's rewrite the same
idea using concise and precise language.
A weathered fisherman stands alone at
the edge of a wooden dock, waves lapping
at the posts. His eyes squint into the
sunrise as he mutters clearly, "She
always loved mornings like this." Let's
break down why this works. Specific
subject, not just a person, but a
fisherman. Clear setting, wooden dock,
waves, sunrise. Visual emotion, the
squinting, the solitude, the sunrise.
They show nostalgia without saying it.
Dialogue with weight. The line reveals a
memory, a relationship, a subtle grief.
Now, let's paste that into VO3. Hits
send. And here is the result. Let's
preview the result.
She always loved mornings like this.
Now we've got a cinematic, emotional
moment. It's clear, focused, and
resonant. All because the words are
doing their job. You can use this prompt
template to create such a strong prompt.
Now, let's move to tip seven. The final
tip.
Tip seven is the final key to unlocking
professional-grade video prompts in VO3.
And it might surprise you. VO doesn't
remember anything between your prompts.
Tip seven, consistency and independence.
Each prompt is its own scene. Treat
every prompt as a standalone cinematic
moment, even if it's part of a sequence.
Don't say next, then, or as before.
Reinclude visual details from previous
shots if they're needed. Vio has no
memory between prompts. Each one is like
a new scene in a short film. So if you
say then he walks into the forest vio
doesn't know who he is. You've lost the
story, the visuals and the emotional
arc. Let's look at a weak example. Then
the same guy continues running through
the forest. This falls apart fast as
there is no reintroduction of subject.
The same guy doesn't tell Vio who he is.
Relies on memory from previous scene.
Vio doesn't have memory. This fails.
Weak continuity. The forest is just
mentioned, not rebuilt visually. No new
description. No emotion, no texture, no
action detail, no dialogue. The
character has no voice again, then
assumes continuity. Vo treats each
prompt in isolation. VO may generate a
totally new person because nothing tells
it otherwise. Now, let's plug this into
VO3 and hit the send button. And here is
result. Let's preview the
result. Yep, the clip is jarring,
disconnected, and vague. It could be any
man in any forest. Now, let's rewrite.
Treating this prompt as a standalone
scene. A tracking shot follows the same
bearded man in a soaked flannel shirt as
he pushes through thick fog among tall
pine trees. He coughs and yells, "If
anyone's still alive, I'm here." Why
this version works? We reintroduce the
subject with visual detail. Bearded man,
flannel shirt. We rebuild the setting.
Fog, tall pine trees. The motion is
defined, pushing through. There's
dialogue and it raises the stakes
instantly. Now let's try this in V3.
Paste the prompt and hit the send
button. Wait for a few seconds and here
it is. Let's preview it. If anyone's
still
alive. Yes, now we're in a scene with
weight, urgency, and cinematic clarity.
You can use this prompt template to
create such strong prompt. So, we've now
covered seven powerful prompt tips for
generating cinematic videos using Google
V3. To make things easier for you, I've
compiled all seven prompt templates into
one neat Google Doc. And you can find
the link to that on our WhatsApp
channel. Don't miss it. But wait, that's
not all. I've gone one step further.
I've merged all these tips into one
final prompt template.
Yes, this is the ultimate prompt
template and it brings together all the
seven tips we discussed earlier in this
tutorial. All you need to do is fill in
the blanks and you're ready to create a
stunning cinematic video using Google
V3. But what if you're short on time and
don't want to manually fill in those
blanks? Well, good news. I've got
something even
better. This is where the real magic
happens. Just copy the magical prompt
template from our WhatsApp channel. Then
head over to chat GPT. Paste the prompt
in and scroll down. You'll see a line
that says, "Enter your idea here."
Simply replace that line with your video
idea. For example, I entered a newly
married couple are in their bedroom on
their first night wearing traditional
Indian wedding dress making a selfie
vlog where the girl says, "Hello guys,
welcome to our vlog." Well, this is an
AI vlog created by Zappiwala using
Google V3. Now, hit the send button and
let ChatGpt work its magic. Within
seconds, it will generate a perfect V3
prompt, incorporating all seven tips we
learned in this video. And boom, here it
is. Let's copy the final prompt. Now,
head over to the Google V3 AI video
generator. Paste it in. Make sure the V3
model is selected and hit generate. Wait
just a few seconds, and bingo, our
cinematic video is ready. Let's preview
it. Hello guys, welcome to our vlog.
Well, this is an AI vlog created by
Zapiaala using Google Veo 3. That's it
for today's video. You'll find all the
prompt templates, including the ones
used in the AI vlog at the beginning,
available on our WhatsApp channel along
with the magical prompt template. If you
learned something new today, please
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the channel. I'm a small
creator, but I pour my heart into every
video and your support means the world
to me. Also, I'd love to hear your
thoughts, so drop your feedback in the
comments below. See you soon in the next
video.